we got another woke company uh pantene
the makers of um pretty much all the
toiletry
all the companies are going woke but
especially in the toiletry realm
uh that's where it's uber woke there so
pantene maker of i believe
shampoo has um become the latest
corporation to jump on the trans
indoctrination bandwagon and i'm going
to play this ad for you
which is a really repulsive and
grotesque ad on many many levels
and i guarantee you if you're a
conservative with you with an anonymous
account and five followers
you can express your outrage over this
ad to pantene and they're not gonna give
a damn
okay they're not gonna do anything in
response to that because they don't care
about you but here's the uh let's play
this this is the ad for panty and this
is um
uh a we're being told about
a young boy who decided to be to become
a girl
and is in the middle of this gender
transition and is being helped along in
that transition by his two mothers
so two mothers um his two lesbian
mothers end up with a boy who wants to
be a girl
what a coincidence i mean that's it it's
got to be you know it's
how could we possibly draw any
connection there at all we we simply
can't
let's watch the ad now here it is
[Music]
so as for lgbtq kids hair is more than
you think
it's how you are seen sawyer is
an old soul she is our
spunky and creative kiddo
sawyer also happens to be a transgender
girl
i remember the first time she was out in
the community
wearing the clothing she wanted in her
hair and she kind of
was herself and that was the first day
where i was not
he's the opposite of himself she has
always been
super gender creative that doesn't mean
anything hair has that doesn't mean
anything gender creative is not
that doesn't mean anything once she told
us that she
identified as a girl she immediately
wanted to grow her hair out
that must mean he's a girl if you wanted
to grow his hair out what other
explanation could you possibly have my
insides match my outsides
this was a kid who knew who she was from
such a young age no he didn't cause no
kid does because they're kids about your
kids
being um loved and accepted so
i'm always telling sawyer to never hide
who she is
always be her oh no no you're you're
telling him exactly that to hide who he
is that's exactly what you're helping
him do
you lunatic you abusive
lunatic everybody loves everybody no
matter what path you follow
it means i can be who i am
no matter what it doesn't matter because
everybody loves me
my advice is just be yourself
and don't let anybody tell you who you
are
[Music]
yeah that poor kid
that poor kid i feel so bad for these
kids what hope do they have
having parents like this having these
lunatic abusive parents i mean that kid
should be removed from the home
and then those parents should be in
prison this is
among the worst forms of abuse that you
could possibly inflict on a child
this is psychological and sexual abuse
uh on
on on such a deep level
that you you are warping
[Music]
everything about them there's their
sense of themselves you are
warping
some of the worst abuse you'll ever see
and it's being
and we're being told about it the
abusive parents are sitting there
the nice inspirational music in the
background
and they're using it to sell shampoo
that's how
accepted and normalized they want this
to be let me tell you something if you
still go out and buy
pantene products whoever you anyone
listen if you go out and buy
pantene products you're pathetic if you
would still go and buy their products
after watching that
this is a this is a company that is
using child abuse
to sell their product
anyone who would watch that and still
buy the product
is a pitiful excuse for a person
if that's not going to convince you
there should not be what if you are a
call yourself conservative i don't care
what you call yourself if you are a sane
normal person
you should never go near another pantene
product for the rest of your life
based on that it is no different
if if this was a if this was an ad
encouraging
physical abuse of a child that we were
being told how that child is is
you know locked in a closet and and
beaten with sticks and stuff like that
and and they were they were telling us
that with the inspirational music
and saying how wonderful it is for the
child
would anyone buy that product ever again
we would be so horrified
would say this is the worst company on
earth
this is no different this is just as bad
if not worse
that is a child who's being ruined by
those parents
ruined
listen what he said he said um
you know when he wears girls girl
clothes his insides match his outsides
now
that that is a perfectly
expected and even reasonable thing to
hear
from a child who's been indoctrinated
into this
by his parents but as adults
we know that that doesn't make any sense
what do you mean what do you mean you
have girl insides that doesn't
mean anything it makes
zero sense as adults we know that
you can't expect a child to know it
unless you tell them
because children don't know anything
unless you tell them
a young boy as i've said a million times
a young boy
does not know who he is you have to help
him figure that out
and when he says i'm a girl he doesn't
know
what that statement means he doesn't
understand what he's saying
and if you don't believe me whenever you
hear a boy say that
all you have to ask him all you have to
ask him is
what do you mean hey sawyer when you say
you're a girl what do you mean by that
what do you mean
that's i ask my kids that kind of
question all the time when they say
things
because they often make statements that
don't make any sense because they're
kids
don't make any sense to me anyway so i
often have to say
what do you mean
and then as they start to describe it i
i was okay so this is what you mean
see because they're gonna they're gonna
use words
that don't line up with what they
actually are trying to express
because they don't have the words yet
because their vocabulary is limited and
they also don't understand their own
emotions yet
because they're psychologically limited
and neurologically limited and their
brains aren't fully developed yet
and so as a parent my job so often is to
figure out what they actually think and
believe and want and feel
and to help them to realize that about
themselves and to help them to express
it
when you sit a kid down for at a
restaurant
to pick a meal they don't even know what
what they want to eat
they'll point to something on the menu
and you'll have to say as the parent no
no you don't really want that
i know you don't want it because i've
gotten you that meal six other times and
you didn't eat it
i know you think you want it but you
don't actually want it i'm gonna order
you the meal that you're actually gonna
eat
we as parents do that all the time
because kids don't know what they want
this is this is not some academic
discussion this is basic
child raising stuff this is this basic
stuff about about child psychology
and to deny it to that extent is is
horrific abuse
please don't ever buy pantene ever again
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content